that's a bourbon
holy look maya i got it yeah you got it
maya was able to pull out lush which was
a big deal because it's a different kind
of fish none of my kids ever seen one
i've never caught one and i was really
proud of her to be able to pull in a
nice lush like that feels good to get a
burbot
my first time ever catching one first
time with the kids they're excited i'm
excited
is she seeing little maya pull it out
that's golden
i can't believe we gotta burp it that's
so cool we still have more lines to
check too oh yeah
oh there's a fish on it
holy that's a big pike that's a huge
pike
dang
oh that's a big bike it's dead it's huge
it'll have a good liver inside of it
now let's tell you the other one
another one
yep
oh it's still alive come on burp it burp
it come on bourbon
it's a perfect oh man it's a huge one
look at it
that's a baby one huge huh yeah
stand right here let's see how big it is
next to you
his tail is on the ground
as big as you mama
okay we're gonna make a little fire and
cook some bourbon have a feast
definitely different looking fish see
how like the flakes are bigger oh yeah
oh look at those moves
yeah baby moose
it looks into her
oh
holy my you're gonna be hunting moose
pretty soon
[Music]
that's the beauty of having kids and
being in the woods and being happy out
here is just part of being with nature
and part of being with your culture is
learning to enjoy yourselves while
you're getting food on the table
my hands are so tired of shaking
[Music]
mm-hmm
yeah
[Music]
geez that fish was gone quick that was
so funny it was no war that was good huh
i just want to fall back and go to sleep
with me too
that's amazing
okay good job maya good job all right
[Music]
you